un nouveau trophée pour les panthères du
fleury loiret handball à savourer sans
modération avec tous ceux qui les ont
soutenus durant la saison
c'est pour eux le travail toute la
saison pour ça maintenant on leur plaire
à tanger au palais des sports en arrive
à rennes personnes on a démarré la
journée en dix ans le partage partage et
rodez d'être transporté d'être sublime
et par tous ces gens qui s'habillent en
rose qui viennent nous voir et douala
c'est l'histoire fantastique de gagner
trois titres nationaux à 12 mois
d'intervalle la coupe de france l'an
passé la coupe de la ligue dont février
et enfin le championnat de france avec
eux ce dernier match face à issy paris
loin d'être résignés les banlieusardes
parisiennes remarquer le pack en milieu
de deuxième période
score final 24 il aura fallu s'accrocher
jusqu'au bout
la joie des panthères n'en est que plus
grande présente une année de boulot et
une année de travail n'est d'émotion et
de finir par un truc comme ça c'est
exceptionnel surtout ici chez nous
faut être deux pour faire une bonne
finale ici à résister résister résister
on a su enfin prendre le pas à prendre
le pas sur elles et avec l'aide du
public et ben du coup ça a été ça a été
parfait derrière donc voilà à quoi bon
boudé son plaisir retour dans ce
chaudron qu'est devenu le palais des
sports pour continuer la fête la joie
mêlée à l'émotion celle des filles dont
c'était le dernier match en rouge
il y aurait en maniant le titre je suis
très content pour ma famille par des
amis à tout le monde de le déplorer
merci c'est très bien fait avec moi les
suis très content mais c'est fortement
les panthères du fleury loiret handball
des filles en or vice-championne
d'europe ou si cette saison des projets
plein la tête
ça promet